a great operator a great entrepreneur a
great leader a great CEO like that's
what you do you work for everybody else
and when you're a great entrepreneur a
CEO is a great leader in that time but
she can leave in three years and be a
different CEO this is my baby for life
this is why people struggle with more
work/life balance when they're
entrepreneurs your business is the next
child
you got your perspective well Gary Vee
welcome to the a-list thank you so much
now you have a Great backstory and I
feel like the people who are watching
this are gonna be in two camps either
they are just stark raving mad lunatics
and followers of you on every device
they own or they're saying hmm who is
this young man and I don't mean to say
that from an older perspective but
you're actually right yeah so give us
some background and I will say I now
know we were talking I've done so much
research yeah that diet I don't know if
you've heard of that diet the whole
thirty diet yes so I've been telling my
family I'm on a whole Gary thing and
I've been listening to you so much that
our 14-year old got in the car yesterday
and there was only like four seconds of
your voice and he goes back here again
let's do it so now he's on the Gary's I
love it
is the cursing okay because when I'm on
not television there is some Jersey
words and they have some yes I will just
say that I glad you brought that up yes
the only F word we use in PBS is
fundings understood yeah this funny
local so I was born in the Soviet Union
okay which has had a huge impact on my
life because a it makes me
disproportionately in love with America
and all its opportunities and I think
it's a grossly underrated even though a
lot of people watching think it's the
risk I think it's better than we even
realize B it means I grew up with very
little we came to the u.s. it was the
late 70s the Jimmy Carter years the
economy collapsed and we lived in a
studio apartment not bigger than this
area that we're in with six seven eight
family members depending on the timing
so it's very humble beginnings but a
very loving family I have an all-time
mom I'm sure through your research
you've become realized she's
disproportionate my hero and I give her
unbelievable amounts of credit for who I
am I was a super entrepreneurial kid you
know it's very rare for somebody growing
up in the 80s who's an immigrant to not
be blindly bought into education as the
way out miraculously I have such a great
mother who saw a four or five set I mean
young five six seven eight year old kid
basically spend all his time on business
lemonade you know I was a four season
executive you know in the fall I'm
raking leaves in the winter I'm
shoveling snow and singing Christmas
carols at your door I mean I literally I
don't talk about that a lot
I literally rang people's doors I'd be
like do you want us will you pay us a
dollar to sing jingle bells me and my
crew I mean it was looted you're Jewish
and I'm Jewish I mean talk about I'm
entrepreneur first you know in the
spring it was like we did a I remember
we did a miniature golf course we did
flee Mart
mini flea markets it was a garage sale
in the summer it was hardcore washing
cars of lemonade I was so passionate and
then very quickly for a lot of people
watching they'll probably remember this
in the late 80s early 90s the baseball
card phenomenon in America happened and
I was at the forefront not only was I
collecting but as a 12 year old I'm in
in hotels in malls in convention centers
set up as a dealer with other 30 40 50
year old men and really cut my teeth
there and then my 14th birthday came and
I first whatever reason I guess that's
grown up in Russia land my dad at this
point in parallel was also an
entrepreneur more a more significant one
saved up all his money as a stock boy
and then manager of a liquor store which
is the job he got in America and bought
a liquor store and dragged me into that
liquor store in Springfield New Jersey
when I was 14 and so from eighth grade
on I worked and so from 14 to 18 my high
school years I fell in love with wine
collecting because my dad had a liquor
store but there was it was an affluent
area of Jersey we were in a middle-class
town but everything surrounding us was
stronger and people would come and they
would
asked for wine and when I found out that
people collected wine that's when it
clicked for me because I wanted to help
my family business badly I wanted to be
part of the family business but I hated
liquor and beer it wasn't interesting I
didn't want to sell Absolut Vodka or
Coors Light but it was a great
intersection because you were selling
lemonade as a little boy and then you
got into baseball so you knew there was
a value in something and the thing that
yeah I selected yes and now you're gonna
be selling leverages liquor all right
collectible - great that's a great it's
a great thought that I haven't thought
of so nice work
yeah and it clicked right away I became
very passionate went to college and
within the first couple weeks of being
in college I saw the internet which was
September of 1994 I went into a dorm
room I saw it it hit me and over the
next year I became infatuated with what
it could be and in 1996 I launched one
of the first e-commerce wine business
one of the first two or three for
ecommerce wine businesses selling wine
on the internet called winelibrary.com
which is the name that I I wanted to
call the business we were called
shoppers discount liquors so we
winelibrary.com was registered in 1998 I
took over my dad's I joined the family
business and really became the operator
of the business because in my college
years during the summer especially
obviously it was clear to my dad that I
was a talented kid and I was making
things happen people are driving from
two hours away to pay 35 35 thousand
dollars worth of wine and I'm 19 years
old am i drinking what but I was so
outrageously right about what wines were
getting hot which wines were getting big
scores if you're watching and you know
wines 90 points 92 points that matters a
lot
build a reputation long before the
internet and and from 1998 to 2005 in a
seven-year window I built my dad's
business from a business that was doing
three million dollars a year to a
business that was doing 60 million
dollars a year and that obviously was a
big deal for an immigrant family I think
it's a big deal also that your dad was
so flexible and dynamic and thought
because I think as an immigrant what I
found is they're like the these are the
rules we're gonna follow here's here's
the goal and let's not you know go
against the grain because it might cause
us to
go back ten steps my my boot sounds
accepting am i doing my dad is
historically underrated for giving me
the air cover I also the reason I say
that is look when you you know I want to
give my dad unlimited credit because he
deserves it
but my dad's smart when you have a 16
year old son who stands behind a
register but takes the initiative to go
through the entire beverage journal
where you order stuff from fines a
closeout of sparkling grapefruit juice
commences the dad to buy it all
it comes it looks like I came out of a
cave but then figures out how to
merchandise it and make signs and sell
it I gave my dad a lot of reasons to
give me air cover but to your point it
takes a level of humility that most
immigrant you want to get really scared
and this is gonna blow your mind d-roc
d-roc is the man that films me all the
time so this is being filmed oh we have
like so many cameras here I don't know
which way to look so the day I started
my dad's store permanently 1998 May of
1998 my dad was 44 years old
I'm 43 as of this second the fact to
think that tomorrow my son or daughter
could be coming into vaynermedia and I'm
giving them the keys to run it it's just
laughable he was not only did he give it
to me they air cover he was a child that
was a kid you know there's 68 year olds
right now that are running the family
business that are not letting their 44
year old son take over yet there's 81
year olds watching right now where she's
not letting her son or daughter take
over the business and they're 60 years
old and my dad was 44 years old and look
he did a lot of back-end keeping he we
were he was involved but I did all the
buying I did all the marketing I did all
the hiring I did it I did it and so he
deserves an enormous amount of credit
and I think hundreds of millions of
family businesses can learn a lot for my
dad's strategies get in
- vaynermedia type sports all of these
things that then use the bane rate the
Vayner Empire also the fact that by the
time you're sixty you're just gonna be G
because you keep shortening your name
like there's I'm afraid you're gonna
have nothing left like you've taken out
the chassis and now you've taken out the
inner feeling that's Gary he's in the
next 17 years I'm able to mark it in a
way that I can Trump Google's G for my G
I'm gonna do okay
in 2009 my brother graduated college we
have decided that point we were gonna do
something together I in 2006 started
Wine Library TV which was a daily show I
would put on YouTube of me tasting wine
that exploded changed the course of my
career in many ways one it taught me
that I was a personality I didn't know
that - it made my wine business explode
three it made me go deeper into what was
called web 2.0 that now we call social
media but these are slang terms for the
current state of the internet that led
me to getting infatuated with Facebook
and Twitter which led me to investing in
Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr which as
you can imagine change the course of my
financial career it led to me writing a
book about the internet and building
reputation and businesses on it called
crush it which was a huge New York Times
bestseller let the company's reaching
out to me and saying we're Pepsi and you
have a million followers on Twitter and
we have sixteen that's weird
we are ready and so one day I called my
brother and said ESPN just pay me $5,000
to come in for an hour and talk about
the internet I'm like we should start a
company around that and I knew that I
wanted to build on my strengths I knew
at 2009 that I wasn't a great liquor
store operator I was a great marketer
that I could point that to anything and
so that's the beauty of self-awareness
and a little bit of experience so we
started vaynermedia and the plan was
let's become an agency for for brands
and let's build a great company and then
let's really use it for ourselves
because having clients at some level was
not our interest
I thought at the time by 2015 16:17 the
economy would collapse again a cycle
because I we're just coming out just oh
wait you know we're building up we'll
have six seven eight years you know and
then when it collapses hopefully the
company will be good and I'll be able to
have money and will be able to buy a
business for a penny on the dollar
because that's what always happens when
the economy collapses but now it's 2019
the economy has not collapsed in a
decade as a matter of fact it's over
frothy and and the company's become
enormous so the idea of like building
this small company and then translating
all the people to the new company is out
the window now much like Wine Library is
doing well
I want vaynermedia to do well forever
even when I go and buy Snickers or Puma
or whatever I'm up to in my next chapter
which is going to be buying a business
and running it
I want Vayner to do great and I think a
lot about that these days and you want
to own the Jets I want to own the New
York Jets which we have a lot in common
they I'll just say because I grew up in
Alabama I'm a huge Alabama fan roll tide
and of course love Joe Namath who played
for the Jets there that's it that's the
bridge I love it that's about where the
bridge ends because unlike roll tide
who win almost every year we lose every
year yeah and so there is a big
difference and by the way just another
little connection Richard Todd was also
an Alabama quarterback who became who's
supposed to be the blond Joe Namath he
was pretty good he was my first
quarterback but it was no joke but is
that how does that aspiration fuel what
you do is it just is that one of the
things you just keep you've said it so
long that now it's become sort of yeah
mantra on the side or is that really
yeah yeah the answer is yes to both I
mean I somewhere around third or fourth
grade I don't remember exactly so I want
to make it up before middle school I
started walking around grammar school
saying I was gonna buy the Jets it was a
very big deal at in middle school in
high school it was the only thing I
talked about so that's a long time ago
and but I have created more clarity over
the last two or three years because I'm
unbelievably passionate about happiness
not about money as a matter fact I'm
unbelievably not motivated by money
I've come to learn that about myself in
the last a half decade because I'm
leaving a lot of money on the table I'm
I'm motivated by the process I'm
motivated by waking up in the morning
and being fired up because I'm in
control of my destiny and I get to do
what I want and that's who I am I'm
somebody who found what and I knew it
from the beginning you know I didn't
realize it but now looking back as we
set up earlier my early actions spoke to
what my passion was I always wanted to
be in business I always wanted to sell
from the beginning from the womb and I
love the chase I love the process which
is why you're the serial entrepreneur
100% you got to keep you got to keep
building real entrepreneurs which is not
what we have now we have a generation of
fake entrepreneurs because
entrepreneurship is cool and I've
benefited from that but I will not be a
hypocrite or milk it I will speak the
truth and the truth is entrepreneurship
is extremely hard it's outrageously
lonely almost everybody fails and a lot
of people right now that say they're
entrepreneurs on Instagram are gonna not
be entrepreneurs in three years when
that's not the cool thing when the
economy collapses and I'm worried about
that because it leads to depression and
anxiety and even the worst of worse
suicide and so yes that is why I am an
entrepreneur and that's why it's very
easy for me to know that we're not
living through an era of real
entrepreneurship because so many people
that I see are entrepreneurs are
actually executives do you think a show
like Shark Tank has been good for the
entrepreneurial spirit or has it both
sort of you YouTube are people yeah it
doesn't make people assume anybody can
do it
the reason it's been both is what I like
about Shark Tank is they show a lot of
people not getting a deal yeah thank God
you know what's bad about you sell you
on Shark Tank that oh yes so that I
flashed my eye it's kind of you know I
also am very passionate about garage
saleing the reason I don't like you know
like all these flippin shows and storage
shows is it's just a highlight reel let
me tell you actually what happens if you
go storage auction hunting 99 of a
hundred of them is a disaster and you
just paid eighty three dollars for dog
poopie and then you got to clean it out
you paid
to work so what shark think has at least
done is shows a lot of times it's no
it's hard it's just meeting after
meeting after meeting to meaning and
work and work and work and so it's
unbelievably lonely being a number one
I'm worried about what's happening in
London LA New York right now and the
well-being of 900 employees right now I
got an email on the way here that the
head of HR sent something to somebody
that said you're you and your daughter
are in our thoughts now I'm like what
happened I'm worried like you have 900
children imagine having 900 children
that's what it is a great operator a
great entrepreneur a great leader a
great CEO like that's what you do you
work for everybody else and when you're
a great entrepreneur a CEO is a great
leader in that time but she can leave in
3 years and be a different CEO this is
my baby for life this is why people
struggle with more work-life balance
when they're entrepreneurs
your business is the next child I have
three children you know and that's the
truth and maybe it's not the most
politically correct thing to say right
now and everybody wants more work-life
balance but a real entrepreneur will
tell you dead in your face in her or his
truest moment my business is my other
child it is my family member because it
is well I'll tell you what was very
eye-opening for me is hearing a lot of
you a lot hearing you speak a lot about
it not just in one context but over and
over again about your luck work-life
balance
yeah and specifically this idea of
breadth versus depth yes and that you're
unapologetic about working 18 hours a
day and all during the week and possibly
not seeing your kids but when you are
off work you are in family yep and when
you are in family you are off work
that's right but people are judging
about that I mean when people see that
are super judging right we Regis Lee
there's a movement of people trying to
make me the face of overworking there
are people right now using my name to
make a point that we're Laura fiying
hard work because they're not spending a
lot of time looking at my content and
realizing I'm talking about happiness
I'm talking about working hard to people
who are complaining if you're unhappy if
and by the way this is 90 percent of the
conversation if you say to me I'm not
happy I can't find my passion I'm not I
don't like my job I'm unhappy my answer
is to use work to find your way out yes
I think when you get home no you should
not complain about it you should not
dwell you should not watch Netflix or
play video games to escape your
unhappiness you should try to start an
internet business at night because it's
practical because your grandmama didn't
have this and use it over a four-year
period to be able to go do that and quit
your job that you hate I don't tell
people to work 18 hours a day and burn
out and have suicidal thoughts when
they're happy I'm talking to people that
complain and dwell and that is 90% of
the market and do nothing about it
correct but complain and well I'm an
action-oriented dude i I just don't know
any other reaction based on being an
immigrant being kind of the man of the
house cuz my dad worked every minute
like all I know is problem solve the
thought of problem cry is completely
unacceptable to me that is what the
masses do so we talked a lot about hard
skills what about the soft skills what
about the skills that I feel like we've
lost in every generation to a little bit
extent because we're not we're not
interpersonal where we are relying on
technology to communicate maybe it's
expose us but it also has allowed us to
go into our own silos and I don't know
about that I mean I think you know I
think it depends on how you define it so
look to me when I think about soft
skills I think about things more like
gratitude and empathy and kindness each
you really what I trade on right I would
argue that technology's allowed me to
scale that you know like why is a letter
or a telephone that was rotary
considered so much better than our
cellphones that are on us at all times
right the fact that I'm looking at the
Iraq the fact that I can text him a
heart emoji and he can know that I'm
thinking about him and I appreciate him
and I'm using soft skills to show him
gratitude yeah I just don't agree I
don't agree that
that light is that heart emoji gonna
replace a hug for your cot for your
child no but I'm not there I get that
little but also like no like for no no
no no let's let's stick on that per
minute is it gonna replace it of course
not but what about when you're not there
like what about when you're not thinking
about it like like again why why do we
put some people you're talking to
semantics and when people talk semantics
they try to put things like a written
letter on a pedestal no but I'm also
talking that I really couldn't care less
if my kids know calculus I'm sorry but I
do care and we have like since the day
they could walk and talk that they shake
someone's hand and look them in the eye
right have said that I worth of Al and I
have 4,000 times the last six months
made fun of people that put that on a
pedestal not because I don't agree I
agree too much you and I are kindred
spirits that's probably why you've been
consuming so much of my content I can
tell already I miss it's that I don't
want what you're talking about is
respect kindness and empathy for another
human being yes you've decided that a
handshake in looking in the eye is the
manifestation of that I don't believe
that to be true or needed in a world
where things evolve I think the spirit
of it is more important than ever and
always actually not more is always the
most important but I'm not going to
require my children to manifest it in
what the current state of a politically
correct version of it is I expect them
to act on it what I love about life is I
have no interest in trying to change
your mind I love that every family and
every parent and every little group of
individuals gets to decide what those
little trinkets are of it but I have no
passion for my children to be
entrepreneurs I have a passion for my
children to be happy the way I am
because I'm an entrepreneur and I was
meant to be one for them and if that's
an artist or a parent or a student or
you know a professor I'm and and I think
that's how I think about the handshake
thing I don't need them to be a
handshake in the eye kid I need them to
manifest kindness respect caring and
things of that nature and I think those
rules evolve those rules evolve your
great great grandmother
thinks it's insane that you're wearing
pants right now that's not she was
pretty cool but that's not what a lady
does in her rules of you being a lady I
think you're a lady so I mean that the
Beatles hair was unacceptable
it just was and so I'm not willing to
like take historic or current social
norms that are the indicator of respect
I actually want my kids to respect
people on that note thanks for being on
the show thanks for having me
[Music]